Johnny Depp ooh he said she said 50
million dollar defamation lawsuit
against his ex Amber Heard the shocking
emergency room photo was taken on March
8th 2015
johnny was partially sedated for pain on
Depp's right cheek is what he claims is
a burn mark caused by amber who he says
put a cigarette out on his face his
finger wrapped in a green bandage yes do
you remember the headlines three years
ago that said Johnny chopped off his own
finger because he was high on MDMA
well this photo offers new insight into
what might have happened et has obtained
the new court documents that have depth
side of the story the claims amber flew
into a rage allegedly upset because
Johnny wanted a post-nuptial agreement
amber threw a bottle at Johnny it
smashed against his hand fracturing
bones and basically chopping off the tip
of his finger
Amber's legal team has fired back
telling et this allegation is absurd
this photograph proves nothing and is
being used to deflect attention from his
physical and ongoing psychological abuse
of amber his lawyer is getting ready for
a fierce legal battle telling et they've
got 31 i witness --is 87 surveillance
videos time and date stamped photos all
of which they believe prove Johnny's
innocence this one's getting messy they
are set to go to trial in Virginia next
February the judge believes it's gonna
take about 12 days and I believe some
lawyers are having a lot of money big
facts yeah
[Music]
[Applause]